bonjour et bienvenue dans ce premier
numéro de parlement hebdo à l'occasion
de la rentrée parlementaire nous sommes
ravis de vous retrouver en compagnie de
michaël szames us bonjour michael
députés et sénateurs ont donc repris la
route des hémicycles deux semaines avant
la date prévue
à l'assemblée les députés ont planché
sur le texte des emplois d'avenir
l'une des mesures phares du programme
hollande les sénateurs ont adopté leur
premiers textes sur le logement social
le parti socialiste s'est choisi un
nouveau premier secrétaire feu sera
harlem désir rien n'est encore officiel
puisque six motions vont se disputer les
votes des militants d'ici au 11 octobre
martine aubry quitte son poste en cette
fin de semaine tout est joué d'avancé se
plaignent les petits candidats ait pas
de jaloux du côté de l'ump cela n'est
pas plus simple pour l'élection du
président du parti
les candidats ont jusqu'à mardi prochain
pour trouver leur 8000 parrainage là
encore les petits candidats se plaignent
de ne pas pouvoir exister face au duel à
coppet triangle est avec nous pour
commenter toute cette actualité henri
guaino bonjour il est de nouveau député
ump des yvelines vous êtes l'ancienne
plume de nicolas sarkozy pendant plus
qu'un quinquennat on va dire vous êtes
également en piste pour être candidat
pour la présidence de l'ump vous avez
déclaré début septembre
mais je peux être juste m'arrêter là
pour ce portrait que je viendrais c'est
pour laisser la parole à vos collègues
vos nouveaux collègues députés ça se
passe ici
regardez comme je les premiers pas ici
récent droits comme n'importe quel
député qui a son premier mandat sans
plus bah oui sans plus ni moins je le
vois beaucoup plus sur les écrans de
télévision que
dans les enceintes parlementaires il
faut éviter aussi de vouloir trop
rapidement monter ses muscles en disant
regardez qui suit c'est moi monsieur x
qui est déjà fait si c'est ça et ça donc
je trouve ça plutôt bien qu'il y est
entre guillemets une approche
relativement modeste je précède que
c'est un député qui est très présent et
très travailleur et je peux vous dire
pourquoi je le sais parce qu'ils aiment
le bureau qui est voisin du mien donc on
a un point commun c'est que la lumière
est allumée tard le soir dans son bureau
comme dans les miens il va constater
qu'on a sans doute moins de pouvoir à
l'assemblée que lorsqu'on est le
conseiller spécial du président de la
république
et puis on gagne moins d'ailleurs
beaucoup mais ça ils aiment pas trop con
qu'on en parle
vous le voyez ou dans dix ans reggae
dont je ne sais pas vous avez la
question je n'ai pas dit dans les médias
entendez si vous sous-entendez parle à
l'elysée entre guillemets vous verrez
bien côté jeu ne sait déjà pas où il
était il ya dix ans donc du coup me
demander ce qu'il fera dans dix ans je
lui souhaite le meilleur naturellement
par thomas ce livre que vous avez
esquissé un léger sourire et comment ça
se passe les relations avec vos nouveaux
collègues alors que vous les avez vus
tous défilé l elysée il doit y avoir un
rapport de force un peu différent non
mais il n'y a pas de rapport de force il
ya jamais eu de rapport de force
ce sont pour la plupart des amis de
longue date sauf les sauf les tout
nouveaux donc tout ça se passe très bien
et puis tu es vous plaît c'est peut-être
un peu tôt pour le dire mais là on
s'attendait à de vocollect disait il va
vite comprendre qu'il arriva alors moins
de pouvoir c'est vrai que 1,1 députés
tout seul à moins 2 je n'ai jamais eu de
pouvoir d'ailleurs mais peut-être moins
d' influence sur la vie de non non vous
savez conseiller ça ne l'est pas ça ne
permet pas d'avoir de décision
je le seul qui décide et qui trace une
ligne disait c'était le président de la
république vont pas moi voilà je hais et
nicolas sarkozy était tout sauf une
marionnette sauf quelqu'un qui on
pouvait dicter sa conduite
je n'ai d'ailleurs jamais songé à le
faire avec les français ça a été
difficile pour vous parce que vous êtes
vraiment passé de l'homme de cabinet à
l'élu vous avez des contacts le week-end
avec avec
les français de votre circonscription
c'est un effort pour vous deux
non non pas du tout moi j'ai toujours
aimé les contacts avec les gens non ça
n'a absolument pas coûter mais enfin
savez je il m'est arrivé d'avoir des
contacts avec des français avant de me
présenter aux élections
il m'est même arrivé de participer à des
campagnes électorales et même la
campagne présidentielle pendant laquelle
j'ai fait un tour de france en allant à
la rencontre des à la rencontre des gens
en est le tenant des réunions publiques
donc vrai mais moi j'aime j'aime plutôt
ça je trouve que c'est plutôt
intéressant de rencontrer les gens de
les écouter de leur parler et c'est le
contraire qui me manquerait dire de ne
pas les voir et de ne pas les écouter et
puis en plus dans l'ensemble y sont ils
sont plutôt gentils on a
malgré ce qu'en écrit vos collègues
pendant ma campagne législative
c'est avec un jour non mais quand même
soyons réalistes non mais quand à jour
est la compagne que vous rencontrez 20
personnes sur votre chemin de sur un
marché que 18 10 échanges gentil et 2 d
horreur eh bien vous êtes sûrs d'une
chose c'est que dans l'article il n'y
aura que les deux qui disent des
horreurs voilà les articles n'étaient
pas très gentil j'ai été élu tant mieux
c'était la meilleure réponse à certains
de vos confrères juste une question et
de nous à l'écrire et vous avez écrit un
livre qui va sortir début octobre
est-ce que ça va être c'est votre vie un
petit peu pendant cinq ans à l'elysée ce
que ça va être un petit peu un brûlot
comme celui de roselyne bachelot qui a
fait le bilan du quinquennat nicolas
sarkozy dit que d'abord je n'ai aucune
comparaison possible
j'ai dit ce que je pensais du livre de
madame bachelot
je sais pas pour faire la même chose non
envoyée c'est un livre politique pas
comme les autres dit du mal de personnes
c'est un livre sur des idées sur une
expérience humaine voilà sur président
de la république aux six mois pour
annoncer 50 c'est oui mais c'est pas non
plus c'est pas non plus une histoire
verbatims etc ces cinq ans c'est ce que
je tire mois de cette expérience là et
puis de mes expériences précédentes
d'ailleurs des rencontres que j'ai
faites sur de méditation sur le pouvoir
la politique la vie aussi après 7 après
cette expérience extraordinaire qui ont
été ses cinq ans passés à l'elysée dans
les circonstances que l'on sait alors
henri guaino on va dérouler ensemble
l'actualité de la semaine c'est la règle
de parler alors on va donc attaquer clos
lundi c'est normal françois hollande a
présenté l'addition de la crise et cela
passe mal
30 milliards c'est donc la facture salée
présenté dimanche soir à la télévision
par françois hollande le président de la
république a détaillé la note 10
milliards de réduction des dépenses 10
milliards d'impôts en plus pour les
ménages dix autres encore pour les
entreprises on n'avait pas le choix dit
le président on écoute je suis en
situation de combat
j'ai pour mission de redresser notre
pays et je vais fixer un agenda du
redressement deux en deux ans pour à la
fois mettre en oeuvre une politique pour
l'emploi pour la compétitivité et pour
le redressement des comptes publics
j'entends bien les impatiences je vais
pas faire en quatre mois ce que mes
prédécesseurs n'ont pas fait en cinq ans
ou en disant à moins bien que c'est un
effort considérable 30 milliards ça ne
s'est jamais fait dans l'histoire de la
vème république et j'ai cette
responsabilité je ne le fais pas
simplement parce qu'il faudrait le faire
je le fais par conviction parce que je
ne veux pas laisser à mes successeurs et
je ne veux pas laisser non plus à mes
enfants
la charge de la dette de la france il
invite toujours les réactions sont
nombreuses
l'ump a même mis une pause dans sa
compétition interne pour riposter le ps
défend les efforts nécessaires et la
gauche de la gauche s'alarme les
réactions recueillies par jérôme
rhabiller moi je n'ai rien entendu qui
permette de dire que d'ici deux ans en
mourra effectivement une relance
économique réelle et c'est quand même un
sacré problème de toujours plus d'impôts
dans un pays qui est déjà parmi les
records européens et d'impôts et
dépenses publiques et dont on ne voit
que ça n'a pas apporté plus de
croissance il faut vraiment changer de
logiciel 25 minutes de thé pour sow
j'aurais juste envoyé un communiqué moi
qui aurais tenu en deux trois mots plus
d'impôts voilà et puis je serais pas
allé à la télé parce que sincèrement on
peut pas dire que ni au niveau oratoire
ni au niveau de la vision de la france
ni au niveau des perspectives
ça a été très clair originaux on est
parti pour deux ans très très difficile
où est alors d'abord se faire une
remarque c'est extraordinaire au bout de
quatre mois
le président de la république tient le
discours exactement inverse de celui qui
l'a tenu pendant toute sa campagne
présidentielle on n'a jamais vu un tel
revirement aussi peu de temps et
finalement une victoire acquise sur un
tel mensonge
bon maintenant il ya un problème d'une
crise a bien découvert kalinka il y en
avait pas c'est à nicolas sarkozy la
crise avant la crise elle a mal à la
barre si la crise avait commencé la
crise avait commencé il ya deux mois
aurait trouvé tout à fait naturel que le
pauvre mari puis 10e et une crise
personne ne l'avait envisagé la ligue
dans sa campagne qu'il faudrait une
politique de rigueur mais bien sûr qu'il
y avait pas la solution pendant la
campagne c'était très simple c'était
nicolas sarkozy responsable de tout du
chômage du pouvoir d'achat de la
situation de l'europe
rado quand il s'en ira et bien tout ira
mieux voilà il est parti tout va plus
mal mais la crise existait déjà n'a pas
découvert la crise
donc c'est voilà c'était un mensonge qui
apparaît aujourd'hui très clairement
c'est vrai aussi la compétitivité
maintenant c'est un problème le coût du
travail qui n'était pas un problème qui
n'existait pas mais maintenant un
problème le traité européen qui était
soi disant un abandon de souveraineté
mais finalement plus un abandon de
souveraineté etc je veux dire que là on
a on a quelque chose d'extraordinaire
c'est l'aveu d'un énorme mensonge ça ne
favorise ni la mobilisation des français
et ça ne renforce pas non plus la
crédibilité de la parole politique voilà
ma première réaction les gentils deux
dixièmes sur le fond je suis fin prêt
figurent deux combats vous y croyez à ce
président de combat il suffit pas de le
dire beaucoup
il s'agit pas de dire que ce soit
crédible comparer à nicolas sarkozy
quand même c'est que on a retrouvé des
indes et parfois des intonations
sarkozienne ou sarkozyste
le problème c'est que c'est un peu le
sarkozysme sans cap sans but sans
cohérence non plus lequel estime une
étude qui démontre nicolas sarkozy et
françois hollande
non mais tout ce qui est reproché à
nicolas sarkozy il le fait mais il ne
prend il ne prend qu'une partie
c'est-à-dire l'apparence je suis un
président de combat sauf que quand
nicolas sarkozy disait c'était un
monstre on allait quand même un peu plus
crédible il l'a d'ailleurs démontré
pendant toute la crise pendant les au
moins au cours des quatre dernières
années depuis la début de la fusion fin
il ne voulait pas pu manquer cette une
de libération du lundi je crois que tout
le monde l'a vu casse-toi riche qu'on à
l'adresse de bernard arnault qui demande
la nationalité belge ne pensez quoi de
cette une moi je déteste des insultes je
pense que le journalisme
ces journalistes se pressaient
d'information oui mais moi ça me fait
pas rire voilà ça ne me fait pas rire
je vous rappelle quand même que lorsque
le président de la république nicolas
sarkozy à l'époque avait dit ça à
quelqu'un il venait de se faire insulter
alors c'est pas bien te présente la
république réponde de cette façon sans
doute mais c'était une main il venait de
se faire insulter par quelqu'un et il a
répondu spontanément mal insulte par une
insulte ça là là c'est pas du tout la
même chose
et puis s'agit c'est un journal qui a eu
le temps de réfléchir à ce qu'il allait
écrire je trouve ça détestable sauf
qu'il ya aujourd'hui des journaux en
france qui se permettent d'utiliser lé
insulte vis-à-vis des gens avec lesquels
ne sont pas d'accord eh bien ça
n'améliore pas le climat politique voilà
qui curiosité vous étiez conseiller
évidemment de nicolas sarkozy à l'époque
est ce que vous aviez mesurer au moment
où il l'a dit que cette phrase aurait
autant d'impact serait un tel désastre
y compris dans la pâte pleurait sur la
deuxième campagne présidentielle sur le
sainsois sûr que ce soit la raison pour
laquelle il semblait tout au long de son
quinquennat
oui mais bon je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui ont compris aussi que des
circonstances dans lesquelles ça s'était
passé n'était l'été
mais poussés à ce genre de ce genre
d'attitude
ce que je regrette c'est que chaque fois
que les journalistes en ont parlé il
n'est pas raconter toute l'histoire
voilà c'est à dire l'insultent du
monsieur quand même ce qui était le plus
choquant dans cette affaire s'était
d'abord que quelqu'un français
s'adressent de cette manière au
président de la république ça c'était au
moins aussi choquant sinon bien
davantage que ce que la réponse du
président de la république mais c'est
pas ça qui nous a fait perdre des
élections présidentielles d'ailleurs qui
peut savoir ce qui fait que il nous a
manqué unis pour cent de deux doigts
mais vous le savez vous non je vous pose
un caniveau vous êtes un spécialiste de
la politique de rien ça va mais personne
ne peut trancher vous étiez aux affaires
moi je suis pas dans la tête des
quelques centaines de milliers de
français qui aurait pu faire basculer le
scrutin
personne ne le sait quand on a un écart
aussi faible il est impossible d'avoir
une théorie définitive sur sur cette
affaire ça ne m'intéresse pas moi la
seule chose qui m'intéresse c'est de
savoir si ce qu'on a fait était bien ou
pas bien si il faudrait gros faire
exactement de la même manière
voilà c'est vers 11h mais peut-on
amateurs de quoi je suis je suis allé
devant les français pour défendre le
projet pour défendre le bilan jeu ça
veut dire quoi droit d'inventaire la
rocade est un petit peu ce qui s'est
passé ce qui n'a pas fonctionné pour
essayer de tuer les non fondation n'a
pas fonctionné c'est est ce que nous
avons toujours pris les bonnes décisions
ce que nous avons toujours pris les
bonnes mesures
ça oui c'est une question que tout le
monde se pose que nous nous posons que
nicolas sarkozy se pose au 6 mai mais ce
projet gelé défendu et se mélangent les
défendu je vais pas maintenant mains
écartées je vais pas prendre mes
distances
ce serait pas honnête ce serait pas
cohérent ne serait pas consécration
oui c'est quelqu'un m'a dit l'autre jour
ce que j'ai dit je voterai le traité à
manier mais vous ce député godillot
mais je les ai participé à cette
négociation gelée à prouver je ne vais
pas faire non c'est juste être
conséquent vouloir les conséquences de
ce qu'on a fait c'est être responsable
et pas dire le lendemain le contraire de
ce qu'on a dit la veille
je pense que ça ça ferait beaucoup de
bien à la vie publique et à la vie
politique mais je reviens sans pardon
parce qu'on a emmené à ce quizz et là le
le commentaire sur sur monsieur hollande
sont ils le font quand même c'est un
sujet majeur aujourd'hui
d'abord ce n'est pas 30 milliards qu'il
faudra pour faire 3 % si on fait 0 8% de
croissance comme il l'a dit il faut pas
35 milliards je reprends les chiffres de
la cour des comptes c'est 33 milliards à
1 % et 35 milliards à 0 10%
et si on fait moins c'est son plaisir
aux 3000 ans voire 40
il va carrément situation donc il en
faudra bien bien bien plus que ce qu'il
dit le problème c'est que en étant assis
au bord de la récession au bord de la
dépression en europe faire une ponction
de 20 milliards 30 milliards d'impôts 35
milliards c'est tout simplement
accélérer la marche vers la récession
il faut peut-être se poser la question
et je le dis aussi à mes amis de
l'opposition d'ailleurs c'est pas le
problème passation à faire 40 milliards
d'économie ou 40 milliards d'impôts vrai
mais de savoir si c'est l'objectif est
toujours raisonnables et s'il va pas
falloir se poser la question de son
adaptation à la situation de l'économie
et des musiciens si on ne s'impose pas
remettre hier dans les allées le plus
grand monsieur hollande et oui mais moi
je me la pose toujours
et monsieur hollande est devenu le plus
grand partisan de l'austérité qu'on ait
jamais vu
en quatre mois il nous fait le tournant
de la rigueur mais ça ne rajoute pas du
tout moi j'ai toujours été construit
politique d'austérité et je ne changerai
pas les jeux grands grâce à nicolas
sarkozy d'avoir essayé de faire le plus
raisonnablement possible le chemin de
l'ajustement budgétaire
voilà bah va avoir cédé à ceux qui
voulaient aller avoir trop vite on va
avancer mais c'est un sujet essentiel
c'est le sucre en sujet aujourd'hui pour
l'europe et pour la france
on va passer à ce qui s'est passé à
l'assemblée le mardi c'était la rentrée
pour les députés pourront évidemment
un mois et demi qu'ils étaient séparés
les députés se retrouvent donc sur les
bancs de l'hémicycle pour le début de la
session extraordinaire premier texte
examiné les emplois d'avenir cent
cinquante mille emplois d'ici 2014 à
destination des jeunes peu qualifiés
venant de zones défavorisées
c'était un projet phare du candidat
hollande et on va voir que à droite tout
le monde
elle n'y est pas opposée c'est un sujet
de valérie brochard l'examen du projet
de loi sur les emplois d'avenir a débuté
cet après-midi dans l'hémicycle quelques
heures plus tôt pour le premier
point-presse ump de la rentrée le
président du groupe s'engager au nom de
toute l'opposition il ya une position
quasi unanime du groupe pour voter
contre ce contre ce texte ensuite au
sein du groupe nous c'est la liberté de
vote mais 80 mais dans l'accord à l'ump
quelques voix dissonantes commencent à
se faire entendre
et si j'étais maire je l'utiliserai
voilà parce que faut voir aussi le côté
inverse c'est à dire que pour une mairie
au pour une association c'est du
personnel à bon marché
voterait pas ce texte qui je pense
qu'ils ne veut pas dire qu'en tant que
maire il puisse pas y avoir un cas ou
deux on allait prendre etc
et en ce qui me concerne je vais
subordonnés ça la nécessité d'avoir un
contrat d'apprentissage ou des choses
comme ça je pense que l'incohérence et
de voter contre ici pour en embaucher
après dans sa commune ou dans son
département il faut être cohérent
jusqu'au bout je regrette vraiment ce
positionnement trouve qu'il ya d'autres
textes qui vont venir où on pourra
s'opposer effectivement frontalement au
parti socialiste est dans cette affaire
nous faisons un mauvais calcul politique
car nous laissons parti socialiste le
monopole des jeunes
on l'aura compris le chef de file de la
droite populaire va même plus loin il
votera pour les discussions sur le texte
continue dans l'hémicycle comme au sein
du groupe ump
alors henri guaino vous avez dit la même
chose que lionnel luca ce que vous
voteriez pour pour les mêmes raisons
juste d'abord une question de forme vous
avez raté le vote semble-t-il je
rappelle votre comme beaucoup de gens
d'ailleurs puisque y avait que quelques
personnes dans l'hémicycle vote était
programmée pour le lendemain je l' ai
découvert je le déplore j'espère qu'il y
aura un vote solennel parce que moi je
ne comprends pas comment on peut la
démocratie peut fonctionner avec des
votes à main levée en catimini avec
quelques députés à 3 heures du matin à
la suite d'un débat qui était
relativement stérile
moi j'ai assisté à une partie de ces
débats bonne partie de ces débats
puisque je suis parti à veille au soir
après l'interruption de séance et sanaa
ça n'avait aucun aucun intérêt c'est à
dire que chacun fait son petit
amendement pour faire parler de lui
l'opposition pendant que détient la
majorité dit non à tous les tous les
amendements de l'opposition et puis on
passe le temps passe au minimum cela
mais en revanche le moment du vote est
un moment de prise de responsabilités
politiques
or moi je suis d'accord est ce que des
et thierry mariani comme lionnel luca
c'est à dire que il faut être cohérent
c'est toujours la même histoire une
histoire tout à l'heure du du traité
traités européens
il faut être cohérent nous là nous avons
fait dans des circonstances dramatiques
des emplois aidés non pas du tout parce
que c'est la solution ça n'est pas la
solution au chômage mais à un moment et
si on peut aider quelques personnes à sa
s'en sortir ou à ne pas sombrer et bien
il faut le faire on bricole chance dans
les ailes dans les crises on bricole
toujours c'est du bricolage vont ce
texte est mal
et en plus très mal fait je trouve que
l'opposé de la majorité a été sourde à
certaines critiques je trouve que
l'histoire du zonage est absurde mais il
ya cent cinquante mille jeunes qui
pourront bénéficier de ce dispositif je
ne me sens pas moralement après que nous
ayons fait la même chose de dire non
deuxièmement c'était très juste ce que
disait lionnel luca et thierry mariani
c'est que les maires les députés maires
qui vont voter non la veille vont aller
demander des emplois non non il faut
être cohérent par des accords au sein
même de l'ump vous n'êtes pas tout sur
cette médecine normal ça qui est des
désaccords c'est pas ça ça n'a rien de
deux d'aberrant je dire que c'est juste
pour se poser vos pensées non mais je
pense sincèrement et je peux les
comprendre que c'est une mauvaise
réponse à la question du chômage
il ya des gens qui pensent certains
d'entre eux pensent que la politique
globale du gouvernement en matière
économique en matière de chômage n'étant
pas bonnes dire oui à ce texte pourrait
ressembler une sorte de quitus pour
toute la politique
moi je ne le crois pas mais je respecte
parfaitement se respecte parfaitement ce
point de vue je demande juste qu'on
respecte le le mien en l'occurrence ça
n'est pas un quitus à la politique
économique du gouvernement
non je la condamne mais moi je ne me
sens pas moralement et politiquement
d'assumer un nom à ce texte voilà même
si c'est un un mauvais texte aurait dû
ne vous étiez pas là au moment du vote
peut-être peut-être manqué l'allocution
de gilbert collard c'est un député non
inscrit qui a fait campagne sous
l'étiquette du front national je vous
propose de l'écouter de réagir juste
après j'ai l'honneur de vous demander de
bien vouloir voter l'amendement suivant
l'emploi d'avenir s'adresse en priorité
aux jeunes de nationalité française et 6
mai que vous ont fait les français mais
que vous ont fait les français
ah bon on peut pas parler de la france
ici ah bon d'accord d'accord dès
l'instant qu'on parle de la france ne
vous écoute anges à la présidence on ne
peut pas parler de la france
vous écouterez avez la parole je vous
laisse je n'ai pas à parler à des gens
qui n'aiment pas la france galop autant
originaux on a bien compris que c'était
l'effet de manche mais ce qu'il ya un
vrai débat de fond
quand il dit finalement le travail pour
les français et je partage pas forcément
cette opinion parce que des gens qui
vivent en france en situation régulière
qui remplissent tous leurs devoirs qui
payent des impôts et que c'est très bien
considérer qu'ils ont droit au
dispositif question mais c'est pas non
plus il n'est pas non plus scandaleux de
dire de poser cette question
enfin en france on peut pas devenir
fonctionnaire si on n'a pas la
nationalité française
bon donc c'est un critère qui existe
dans un certain nombre de situations et
de cas donc on peut légitimement en
discuter jeu
ce que je ne comprends pas c'est ni
l'outrance d'un côté ni l'outrance de
l'autre voilà c'est pas scandaleux ce
n'est pas du racisme
ça n'est pas du nationalisme que de
poser la question bon monsieur collard
dont je ne partage pas les idées pose
cette question on peut au moins les
l'écouté et en débattre voilà tout ce
que je demande c'est que on puisse
s'écouter les uns les autres même quand
on n'est pas d'accord
là il n'ya rien parce qu'il a dit
franchement il n'y avait rien de honteux
je le reconnais là ce qu'il a dit non on
dira que déposer cette question on peut
être contre et on peut en débattre
mais cette cellule hurlements ses
vociférations ne sont pas de mise
je vois là et on va avoir les mêmes sur
le droit de vote des étrangers
ben moi je considère que kaboul à bord
étudiants des crs a le droit de vote
c'est réservé aux français ces deux
questions que je me posais non c'est ce
que ça n'est pas la marque même de la
nationalité est ce que il faut ouvrir la
fonction publique au non français on a
déjà ouvertes aux européens pour des
raisons très particulière mais ben moi
je ne suis pas d'accord pour qu'on ouvre
aux autres par exemple le jeu voilà je
ne le sens pas pour autant ni
nationaliste dit raciste ni xénophobe
aller mardi encore la mise de la justice
christiane taubira dévoile dans la croix
les grandes lignes du projet de loi sur
le mariage homosexuel drouot mariage de
l'adoption mais pas d'accès à la proue
création médicalement assistée voici
quelques réactions qui ont été
recueillis à l'assemblée après cette
annonce personnellement sur le fond je
suis opposé au mariage homosexuel et je
suis encore plus opposés à la
possibilité d'accorder le droit
d'adoption aux couples homosexuels vous
savez très bien que j'ai déjà voté quand
s'était présenté à l'ordre du jour du
parlement une proposition de loi
permettant l'ouverture du mariage aux
couples de même sexe n'est pas de raison
que je change sur le fond maintenant on
verra jusqu'où va le gouvernement sur
ces sujets de la parentalité sur ce
sujet de l'adoption de l'awb la
procréation assistée
sur tous ces sujets là tout dépend de
l'amour mais le curseur donc attendons
de voir le projet définitif
moi je pense que la procréation
médicalement assistée ne doit pas faire
partie de cette loi qui est une loi sur
le mariage et l'adoption mais qu' on
devrait réviser nos lois sur la question
de la pma et de la gestation pour autrui
il n'est pas normal qu'aujourd'hui la
pma ne soit réservé que à des couples
hétérosexuels et pour des raisons
médicales
les couples homosexuels doit pouvoir en
bénéficier
alors autant de députés autant d'avis et
c'est totalement transcourants à le
texte pourrait arriver en conseil des
ministres fin octobre être examinée
ensuite à l'assemblée votre position
vous voulez je suis opposé au principe
du mariage homosexuel jeu parce qu'il
pose là non seulement la question de la
filiation gré d'options il va poser
aussi qu'on le veuille ou non la
question de la procréation médicalement
assistée de ce qu'ils appellent de ce
que monsieur mamère belle la procréation
pour autrui ce qui si bien ce que ça
veut dire
voilà moi ça me pose problème de valeurs
de civilisation d'ordre social
je je je dis pas voyez pas de souci non
mais c'est un grand débat de société
c'est un débat où chacun notre en chèque
ça avec sa conscience c'est moi j'ai
j'ai été élevé par deux femmes ma mère
et ma grand mère ben c'est ma famille je
je je dois rire ou un amour et une
reconnaissance éternelle
mais pour autant je ne fait pas que le
modèle de la famille sanctionné par
exécution ça soit celui de deux femmes
ou deux hommes mais je comprends très
bien que l'enfant qui a été élevés par
deux femmes deux hommes quelles qu'en
soient les raisons soit attaché à sa
famille il ya dans cette affaire
beaucoup de deux aussi beaucoup de
souffrance beaucoup de frustration et il
faut il faut en tenir compte et il faut
que là aussi que nous nous respections
les uns les autres c'est à dire que ce
débat ne doit surtout pas devenir
caricatural il faut se garder de tout
outrance de toute insulte et il faut
dans le respect de chacun
les métèques le débat à l'assemblée sur
morat le souhaitait que le débat l'un
centré soit ouvert cela vous des plans
même lorsqu'il n'y est pas je n'ai je
souhaiterais même
c'est jean leonetti qui nous en a parlé
longuement dans notre dernière réunion
de groupe
ce souhaiterait même qu'il y ait un
débat national sur cette question en
tout cas une consultation nationale
on en discute pour l'instant on n'en est
pas là le référendum ça ça c'est vrai
que ça rend les choses très brutal c'est
une question très brutal donc si on
pouvait février où ça devrait faire un
deuil oui alors je à la fin j'en je sais
pas si ça sera la forme de forums de
l'identité nationale à une époque il ya
eu d'autres forums et d'autres débats
heureusement mieux réussi que celui là
hein mais je pense qu'on peut pas se
passer d'une discussion avec la société
sur une question de ce genre voilà parce
que c'est une question qui touche très
profondément aux croyances aux valeurs à
la conscience de chacun et que le
gouvernement une majorité né n'a pas un
mandat pour toucher sans précaution à ce
genre de choses je le dis très très très
profondément parce que c'est contre
l'affiliation la procréation tout ça ce
sont des choses qui sont très très
profond donc en discuter le plus
sereinement possible
le plus normalement le plus
respectueusement possible tous ensemble
me paraît en tout cas quelque chose
absolument nécessaire voilà pour encore
une fois ma position sur sur le fond son
principe elle était née elle est très
claire on pourra en discuter plus
longuement le longuement mais mais voilà
je trouve ça mérite quand même une
discussion approfondie avec les chaînes
nationales
henri guaino a passé au mercredi la
fumée blanche est enfin sorti de la rue
de solférino
voilà c'est la fin d'un long suspense au
parti socialiste martine aubry jean marc
ayrault avec le numéro 1 et le numéro de
futur numéro un futur numéro deux du
parti socialiste
ensemble à la mutualité à paris c'est un
reportage à la mutualité de johan raud
là à en croire les rumeurs de nombreux
heurts auraient été nécessaires à
martine aubry et jean-marc ayrault pour
finir de s'entendre sur les contours de
la future direction du parti
cet après midi pourtant fin des
tractations
place au spectacle nous avons pensé avec
jean marc ayrault avec tous les
responsables de kiss-in notre
contribution notre motion que à la fois
harlem et emporté l'ensemble de cette
rénovation de ce
et guillaume bachelay qui a été un
acteur fondamental du projet qui a
apporté beaucoup et terna et en plus
d'acteurs et bien que là nous avions un
bon duo si je puis dire aujourd'hui
c'est le message de l'unité et du
rassemblement que nous voulons présenter
harlem désir numéro 1 guillaume bachelay
numéro 2 à leurs côtés pour l'essentiel
des fidèles de martine aubry et de
françois hollande rejoint par plusieurs
proches de benoît hamon une motion de
synthèse pressenti pour recueillir une
écrasante majorité sans pour autant
faire l'unanimité
de son côté le sénateur gaëtan gorce
présentera une motion pour plus de
transparence dans la désignation des
cadres du parti
si on ne peut pas voter demain sur le
choix des gros mais ce créateur c'est
parce que naturellement ça remettrait en
cause les équilibres qui ont été
négociées sur les coins de table ce
n'est plus possible d'avoir un parti qui
fonctionne comme ça nous avons franchi
une étape avec les primeurs on a dit que
la transparence et le pouvoir était
donnée aux militants et aux
sympathisants
deux autres motions seront présentés par
des figures historiques de l'ailé gauche
du ps
l'une par gérard filoche l'autre co
signé par marie noëlle lienemann et
emmanuel maurel qui prennent ainsi leurs
distances avec la politique économique
du gouvernement sur la question
européenne ça fait longtemps qu'on a
déjà un autre socialiste
et ça continue voilà donc on veut être
utile au gouvernement on va être utile à
la gauche et on pense que cette utilité
est justement elles se débattent dans le
congrès pas autre part si ce soir le nom
du premier secrétaire ne laisse guère de
doute
six motions au total seront présentés
aux militants au futur congrès de
toulouse qui promet donc son lot de
débats et peut-être même quelques
surprises originaux je ne devrais pas
votre choix entre harlem désir jean
christophe cambadélis on sait que c'est
pas votre parti par contre françois
hollande lui ne devait pas formulé en
tout cas c'est ce qu'il avait annoncé
aux français on a appris qu'il avait
passé un petit coup de fil pour mettre
fin à un petit peu aux guéguerres c'est
son rôle
bcc pas son rôle de président mais le
président de la république ne peut pas
se désintéresser de ce qui se passe dans
le parti majoritaire puisque c'est une
majorité présidentielle ont finalement
c'est un leurre le général de gaulle
s'occupait aussi de temps en temps de ce
qui se passait à lui d air ou à lui est
né
dans les années 60 il ya qu'elle soit
non mais c'est pour ça que les procès
qui lui ont été intentés sont absurdes
autant le président d'alinto naître un
chef de parti autant il peut pas se
désintéresser de l'avis de la majorité
qui soutient son gouvernement ça n'est
pas ça n'est pas possible on découvre
aussi que finalement toutes les
décisions remonte à l'elysée que tous
les arbitrages c'est lui qui les fait
comme il s'est en plus entourées de
taille à nommer un premier ministre qui
n'a pas une personnalité politique
une autorité politique très forte jean
marc ayrault il n'y a pas une politique
non là on voit bien enfin moi je lis vos
je lis les commentaires dans la presse
et je regarde notre avis à votre avis
non à mon avis il a appris les
personnalités politiques qui pouvait
être totalement autonome au fond bon
d'ailleurs ce n'était pas sous ses pas
souhaitable que le premier ministre vis
à vis tout seul mais enfin c'est pas
georges pompidou sous la série
d'orateurs
mais je moi je n'ai jamais trouvé que
c'était une femme en la preuve de l'émoi
même été et le général de gaulle ne
disait pas autre chose il avait
d'ailleurs nommé georges pompidou qui
était son directeur de cabinet à
matignon
et ça n'a pas fait de pompidou pour
autant espèces domestiques mais oui
d'une certaine manière le premier
ministre et le premier collaborateur du
président de la république je vous
rappelle que ville est nommé que le
président de l'apic lui était lu par la
totalité des français
bon donc cesser la légitimité n'est pas
la même l'exécutif c'est le président de
la république
le législatif c'est le parlement entre
les deux c'est l'ambiguïté la grandeur
de la vème république il ya un premier
ministre et un gouvernement responsable
devant le parlement et devant le
président de la république qui l'a nommé
je vous rappelle que en plus présent
avec 8,9 chacun des ministres on va
continuer harlem désir donc arrive à la
tête du parti socialiste et à l'ump qui
arrivera à la présidence vous faites
partie des candidats vous avez jusqu'à
mardi pour trouver vos emails parrainage
évidemment où poser la question mais
vous allez nous dire tout ça mais on va
d'abord faire un petit rappel de la
situation et des positions de chacun
avec paul bouffard c'est une campagne
qui aura marqué les esprits
depuis plusieurs semaines les candidats
à la présidence de l'ump ont fait de
cette élection un véritable pugilat
tout le monde veut être l'héritier du
sarkozysme
dans la course à la présidence du parti
les chefs se font la guerre
d'un côté jean françois copé le
secrétaire général de l'ump continuent
d'attaquer l'ancien premier ministre lui
s'oppose aux candidats des barons de
l'ump jean françois a raison de se poser
en candidat du peuple militants du peup
le militant qui n'a pas se laisser
dicter de choix par les sondages sur les
sympathisants etc
c'est plutôt est-ce qu'il ya le candidat
des adhérents est le candidat des
sympathisants est-ce qu'il ya le
candidat d'une opinion publique qui n'a
pas une vision du fonctionnement du
parti
mais qui a plus l'idée 2017 que 2012
2015 c'est plutôt ça la différence pour
moi dans le camp fillon
la ligne jaune est franchie par
jean-françois copé c'est vrai que ces
derniers temps un grand nombre d'élus
ont rejoint la candidature de françois
fillon est appelé à soutenir cette
candidature mais si ces élus appellent à
soutenir françois c'est peut-être tout
simplement qu'ils écoutent leurs
militants et peut-être tout simplement
que françois fillon est le chouchou de
leurs militants et au milieu de ce duel
à couteaux tirés
la démocratie a du mal à trouver sa
place plusieurs ténors du parti
interpelle le secrétaire général sur
l'organisation de la campagne sur les
conditions du scrutin certains des
petits candidats tentent d'exister pour
eux difficile de faire entendre leur
projet à bien entendu je suis un petit
candidat je n'ai pas la notoriété d'un
françois fillon ou d'un jean françois
copé c'est normal les petites phrases du
camp fillon contre le camp copé du camp
copé contre le conte fillon moi c'est
pas ma tasse de thé débat d'hommes
plutôt que débat d'idées pour l'instant
l'ump et loin de l'unité
l'air de rien à l'arrivée le 18 ou le 25
novembre
théoriquement on se rassemble basse et
on continue comme ça elle rassemble va
être difficile
alors vous faites partie des petits
candidats qui ont tenté d'exister
non mais je me sens pas partie des
candidats qui vont tenter d'exister un
dit non c'est pas tenter d'exister c'est
il ya des procédures les procédures qui
te sens prévu dans les statuts sont
absurdes
tout le monde le reconnaît aujourd'hui
saint pandelon jamais servi pour la
première fois le savent on se rend
compte que j'essaie avant de vous
présenter donc mais moi oui parce que je
me suis présenté à la fin parce que je
ne supportais plus ce spectacle mais
mais quand on a lancé le processus en
juin deux personnes ne se souvenait de
ce qu'était réellement les règles et
d'un état pris la mesure de leur inanité
enfin ce site c'est juste un praticable
vous avez céline et de parrainage du
nombre de veaux par l annonce arrive on
va bien voir mais mais vous savez il
faut bien un faut bien comprendre
il faut bien comprendre une chose c'est
que premièrement 8000 de parrainage est
une vraie campagne
bon vous pouvez pas aller chercher un
parent ça n'est pas vrai d'ailleurs les
grands candidats font pas ça un et
secrétaire-général donc il parle aux
militants tous les jours à travers ses
folies mais ça c'est après tout c'est
normal quand un président de la
république en exercice qui se présente
c'est pareil mais bon pourquoi pas de
l'autre côté vous avez un ancien premier
ministre qui rassemblait des réseaux
d'élus alors là c'était très simple les
élus que c'est ce qu'ils font ils
remplissent les les bulletins et puis
les donne à signer à leurs proches sont
pas soit que la triche au bouillonnant
vous allez moi quand quelqu'un quand un
mythe on rentre dans une dans une
permanence c'est arrivé l'autre jour et
qu'on demande un bulletin pour me
soutenir et qu'on me donne un bulletin
avec le nom déjà écrit dessus et qu'on
refuse de lui en donner un sens bleus
n'ont écrit j'appelle pas ça de la
démocratie bon mais façon c'est
impraticable de satu sont impraticables
on est en arrêt devant donner un
résultat sans doute tout à fait absurde
et deuxièmement la manière dont les
choses se passent narines avec une
démocratie
moi je vais à l'exercice il est raté
c'est ça l'exercice est ratée absolument
d'exercice est ratée je le redirai
d'ailleurs je le dirai demain
en savoie puisque d'un accoyer a réuni
tous les candidats je leur dirai et je
leur dirai qu il faut se dire la vérité
quand on est entre amis à l'intérieur
d'une famille politique il faut se dire
la vérité de la vérité c'est que cet
exercice est ratée alors c'est pas parce
que les socialistes font pire
et ils font pire des arrangements de la
le rideau same same same sykora et du
sort allait mal élu mais sera élu bon
voila il sera élu maintenant répondre ah
voilà il sera élu bon il rend président
à l'ump qui remplira les fonctions de
président mais une collègue m'a dit
voilà il est un peu cherché le chef non
pas du tout c'est pas en chef sera le
président de l'ump
et puis voilà c'est pas non plus devant
moi je vais pas chez moi je l'achève
vous savez un chef c'est soi-même qui
décideront de suivre quelqu'un bompas
soi quand on le disait est ce que vous
êtes un inconditionnel de tel ou tel
dire moi j'étais inconditionné une fois
dans ma vie c'était du général de gaulle
bon je l'aurais peut-être été aussi si
j'avais eu l'âge j'ai suivi nicolas
sarkozy pour un tas de raisons
bon et j'ai accepté et j'ai accepté cela
tout en gardant la liberté de dire
bonjour et bien là il n'ya pas nicolas
sarkozy ya pas le général de gaulle n'ya
pas phillips et bien non plus disons que
je me rallie aux fantômes de nicolas
sarkozy nommerait un président un chef
et certainement pas le candidat aux
présidentielles de 2017 nous pourrons
parleront sans le moment venu ce n'est
pas le moment on est bien d'accord que
vous êtes très peu de chances d'avoir
vos parrainages verrons ça dépend
imaginez les eyzies que vous les ayez
pas je vais y arriver vous ranger
derrière qu'1 fillon et du souper génère
j'ai d'abord je ne me range derrière
pearson peut-être un moment le dirait je
ma préférence je ne me range derrière
pearson vous savez j'ai sans cesse
le 6 mai j'ai cessé d'être le
collaborateur de quiconque
voilà je peux être ça reviendra mais je
choisirais moi même et pourtant la seule
dit que le gaulliste social celui de ses
ministres c'est françois fillon ah mais
ça c'est vous qui le dites il à vos
parrainages et bien lui qui vous
ressemble plus que ça serait fort sa
fille vous croyez qu'il me ressemble
beaucoup regardé onesta il a raison je
crois qu'il a glissé qu'il a il a dit
quoi sarkozy avait plein de choses en
commun puis on avait des différences et
bien avec françois fillon nous avons
plein de choses en commun et nous avons
des différences si je me reconnaissais
pleinement dans l'eau ou dans l'autre je
n'aurais pas présenter ma candidature
moi ma candidature les tresses un jeu
qui est plus de démocratie bien sûr et
plus de gaullisme à l'ump
bon alors si tout le monde devient
gaulliste et si tout l'interprétation
chacun devait se rapproche de la mine
j'en serai ravi
pour l'instant je me retrouve pas assez
pour soutenir ne nous l'autre des deux
candidats nous verrons au cours de la
campagne
même sans ça les ponts sur les
parrainages la semaine prochaine du
congrès nage c'est la règle c'est comme
ça même si elle est absurde aux
militants de choisir mais vous savez
tout le monde n'a pas chez lui une
imprimante a passé lui une photocopieuse
tout le monde ne sait pas où trouver le
bulletin quand il n'a pas internet
bon tout ça les choses que voilà vous
avez dansé l'absurde voilà je vois là il
faudrait selon m il faut arrêter ces
ratés il faut en tirer les conséquences
voilà c'est son visage vous propose
aussi de passer au jeudi le sénat satair
est un texte sur le logement
et c'est le premier texte examiné lors
de cette session extraordinaire au sénat
il concerne le logement et notamment une
mesure phare le relèvement de 20 à 25%
du taux de logements sociaux dans les
communes cette modification va entraîner
des pénalités financières beaucoup plus
importante pour ceux qui ne respectent
pas la loi
reportage et explications sophie normand
multiplier par cinq les sanctions pour
les villes qui ne respectent pas le taux
de logements sociaux
pour cet élu local c'est un coup dur
d'autant que le délai pour atteindre ces
objectifs passe de 20 à 12 ans pour
construire non plus 20 mais désormais
25% de hlm c'est aberrant parce qu'on
nous demande de construire d'un côté et
puis de l'autre côté on va nous retirer
les moyens qui sont nécessaires pour
construire les équipements publics
dans les faits ce durcissement des
sanctions comme la hausse à 25 % de
création de logements sociaux ne devrait
concerner que les communes qui traînent
des pieds pour rattraper leur retard
il y en a un certain nombre d'onces et
c'est là qu'ils sont visées celles qui
sont en déficit de logements sociaux et
qui font des efforts c'est à dire qu'il
est qu'ils aient qui s'investissent qui
achètent des terrains qui travaillaient
des promoteurs des partenaires sociaux
et ce sont des bons élèves
elle ne rateront pas le déficit de
logements de 20 % ou 2 25% tout de suite
personne dans une dynamique vertueuse et
positive et ne seront pas sanctionnés
encore faut-il que l'état parvienne à
apprécier la bonne ou la mauvaise foi
des élus
la mesure touchera les communes qui
jusque-là préféré payer plutôt que de
construire à 140 euros en moyenne par
logement manquant le montant est
aujourd'hui trop faible pour être
incitatif
on a compris que les sanctions allaient
quintuplé pour ceux qui ne respectent
pas la loi
cette loi qui passent 20 à 25% c'était
déjà très difficile de faire appliquer
cette loi avant % pour les pour les
communes est-ce qu on ne tirera pas un
petit peu trop loin
moi je n'aime pas cette approche en
terme de quotas qui touche finalement
absurde parce que la discrétion du à
sion oui ben quand on fait des logements
souffert des ghettos de pauvres dans des
ghettos de riches sap améliore pas la
mixité sociale construire des logements
sociaux dans un endroit où le foncier
atteint des prix vertigineux
c'est totalement absurde pense faire ce
genre de choses sans s'occuper du reste
de la politique du logement
il ya beaucoup
gens qui sont qui aujourd'hui a vite
demandé dans des hlm dans le logement
social qui n'ont rien à y faire mais qui
ne peuvent pas en sortir tout cas dans
certaines zones très tendues
parce qu'il n'ya pas de logements
intermédiaires accessible donc tout le
problème et pas ce problème ne se résout
pas en termes avec des quotas qui sont
des mesures aveugle je déteste les
quotas dans tout donc là aussi
voilà mes et puis si on veut faire des
quotas alors il faudrait faire aussi des
quotas mis maximum de logements sociaux
dans certains quartiers parce qu'il ya
des endroits où il ya 80 % de logements
sociaux 90% bon d'envoyer ses je trouve
que c'est une approche tellement
simpliste tellement caricaturale que
finale elle finit par être paraître un
productivisme que vous dénoncez sur
quasiment tous depuis quand vous
entendre le début de cette émission
c'est quelque chose que vous dégusterez
politique de françois hollande et jean
marc ayrault de ce gouvernement depuis
le début
moi je les zonages et les quotas ont
fait la preuve de leur imbécillité si je
puis dire c'est à dire c'est une pause
il tout le monde l'a fait à la droite la
gauche entend les mots de françois
fillon qui a dit que c'est une politique
imbécile
voilà mes mais oui c'est vrai voyons
tout mais on n'a pas besoin de se
rapprocher on a des points d'accord on
se connaît depuis longtemps on a
fréquenté les mêmes personnes et on
appartient maintenant aux politiques que
sont la pratique du verglas bien sûr
heureusement que puis il a été premier
ministre pendant cinq ans et moi le
court c'est spécial du président dont il
était premier ministre alors c'est pas
anormal mais je trouve que c'est voilà
c'est prendre les choses comme ça c'est
absurde c'est il ya tout à revoir dans
notre façon d'appréhender la politique
les quotas les critères quantitatifs
ça ne mène à rien voilà c'est il valait
mieux faire le grand paris vraiment pour
en faire un laboratoire de la nécessité
sociale
ce que les élus de gauche parfois de
droite et le prix aujourd'hui le
gouvernement ne veulent pas réellement
faire voilà c'était quand même une
meilleure façon de procéder
henri guaino merci d'avoir est avec nous
tout au long de cette émission vous
aurez appris cette semaine donc pour ne
pas rater un vote à l'assemblée il faut
être là tout le temps ce qui est le sien
voilà non perçues si ça avait un sens si
j'avais une utilité oui mais là ça
n'avait aucun sens à l'apprentissage du
métier de député merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous et nos michael on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine
janadi a pas d'âge pour apprendre